[Music]
the ten make that nine habits of very
organized people today on twitter
actually i tweeted that i was appearing
on your show tonight and that you're
going to uh
hold the book up with magnaminity
which is a word i made up magnaminity
magnaminity yeah so whatever you think
magnaminity might be
it feels yes
yes
you defined it so clearly
it's a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
how long have you been on twitter well
i've been on twitter about a year and a
half
and but then i realized you know
all of us have been if anybody who's
kept you trying to throw that off no i
didn't i did
anybody who's ever kept the journal
really has been tweeting to themselves
because they are short
little entries yes and you know i have
actually kept a journal
of uh all my
my whole life uh
of and i realized i have kept a journal
of my appearances on your show really i
made a little
records and comments of how i thought
the show went and i brought it down
tonight so this is even long before
twitter you were making uh little
comments about this is fascinating i
know isn't that fascinating it is
so i thought i would read what i thought
how the show here's uh december 8th
2007. did conan o'brien show went well i
was very hot audience was good uh conan
seems sluggish
january 6 2008 did conan o'brien very
hot show had some great ad-libs
uh
conan seems sluggish
did his dog die
[Laughter]
june 15 2009 had dinner with conan
always loved spending time with him to
practice fake laughing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let me explain a little bit about this
yes you know people go you're crazy uh
but um
yeah all my
not you me
all the proceeds are going to charity
for me because i include tweets by uh
responses because i think they're very
very funny so i just want to explain
that cool you have your tweets and then
some of the responses you get and uh you
actually you upset some people because
uh and i remember when you're doing this
you started uh tweeting you said you
were tweeting from jury duty right and
uh people uh took you at your word yeah
but i wasn't you weren't you weren't but
yeah but uh some very uh some very funny
tweets in here this was the first one
you did support from jury duty defendant
looks like a murderer guilty
waiting
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here's another one right here these are
real tweets that you sent out from
jerry's the next one that's your stupid
believe in hexes
plus they want me to put my magazines
away
[Laughter]
oh and then uh there was another one
that caught my eye i remember when this
went out
[Applause]
i remembered seeing that and then uh you
did uh include a response i include
other responses from people yes
responsible people this one i i thought
was uh particularly interesting response
this is a real response that you've got
i think i'm the only person in the world
that truly understands you and gets your
humor that said you're not tripping
it's nice to be brought back to earth
yeah occasionally you know it's a social
medium you have to include the good with
the bad exactly everything's not all
wonderful there well uh you know it it's
such a i love it when you're on the show
thank you very much then
you forgot your journal yeah you've got
your journal i can i could really feel
when the end is coming yeah yeah hey
should i i uh should i uh put in my
thoughts about tonight yeah you might as
well you've done it for every other team
okay
you should do that
audience very hot
andy delightful
conan
[Music]
seemed
that's that's not the word i'm thinking
of row
row robotic
[Laughter]